Text graphic appears: Publishing your app
on Google Play is just the start...
Google Play Console logo appears
Google Play Dashboard appears on monitor.
Text overlay: Increase app quality
Get better ratings
Android vitals overview
appears on monitor.
Zoom in on Google Play dropdown menu
Pre-launch report appears on monitor
Text graphic:
Netflix reduced the app crash rate
by 70% in 3 months with Android Vitals
Text graphic 1:
Cooking Craze reduced Crashes 21%
Text graphic 2: Erudite reduced bugs
and improved retention 60%
Device catalogue dashboard
appears on monitor.
Text overlay:
Manage releases with ease
Text graphic: Drupe's crash free
user ratio improved to 99.7%
Text graphic: Omnidrone increased
engagement + 50% and revenue + 20%
Acquisition report dashboard
appears on monitor.
Text overlay: Understand your audience
Improve retention
Examples of review and ratings
appear on mobile phone.
Text overlay: Aviary saves
5-10 hours per week on ratings and reviews
Store list experiments dashboard
appears on monitor.
Text overlay:
Increase your installs
Text graphic:
Hashcube increased installs 88%
Papumba downloads up 30% in 12 months
by localizing in to 15 languages
Google Play Console Overview dashboard
on monitor.
Text overlay:
Earn more revenue
Text graphic: Bombsquad increased
average revenue per user 140%
Text graphic:
Viki increased subscriptions revenue 200%
Google Play Console Dasboard on monitor.
Text overlay: Get support
Help chat box appears
Text overlay: Get started at
g.co/play/console
Google Play Console logo